The passage this morning is going to be read from Ephesians chapter 2 verses 1 through 10.
That's Ephesians chapter 2 verses 1 through 10.
And you were dead in the trespasses and sins in which you once walked,
following the course of this world, following the prince of the power of the air,
the spirit that is now at work in the sons of disobedience,
among whom we all once lived in the passions of our flesh, carrying out the desires of the body
and the mind, and were by nature children of wrath, like the rest of mankind.
But God, being rich in mercy, because of the great love with which he loved us,
even when we were dead in our trespasses, made us alive together with Christ,
by grace you have been saved, and raises up with him and seated us with him in the heavenly places
in Christ Jesus, so that in the coming ages he might show the immeasurable riches of his grace
in kindness towards us in Christ Jesus, for by grace you have been saved through faith.
And this is not your own doing, it is the gift of God, not a result of works so that
no one may boast, for we are his workmanship, created in Christ Jesus for good works,
which God prepared beforehand, that we should walk in them. This is the word of the Lord.
Good morning everyone, it's such a blessing to be here with you this morning.
I met Brandon when he first came over and was talking about church planting, and
we got off to a good start, and here I am this morning. So I thank you for this opportunity,
Brandon, and hopefully, well I know the Lord will bless, but I won't mess up too badly and keep
things going for you. The Book of Ephesians chapter 2, as we study this passage this morning,
I'd like for us to think about understanding my spiritual condition. What is your personal
spiritual condition? And we're going to look at this as we look at Ephesians 2, 1 through 5.
So let's pray before we get started, all right?
Father in heaven, we humble ourselves in your presence, and we come with confidence to your
throne of grace under the leading of the Holy Spirit and through the Lord Jesus Christ.
Please forgive us of our sins and iniquities and blot out our transgressions.
Creating us a clean heart, O God, and renew a steadfast spirit within us that we may continue
to worship you in spirit and in truth. Keep the evil one from us. Help us to focus on your word.
Holy Spirit, please teach us what you want us to learn and empower us and enable us
to live our lives in a manner that's pleasing and honoring to you.
May your children be strengthened and encouraged in their relationship with you as we worship you
today. And Father, I pray that anyone here today who doesn't know Jesus Christ as their Savior,
they would come to know Jesus in a personal way, being freed from their bondage of sin and death,
and experience your love, your grace, your mercy, and your forgiveness. And I ask all
this in Jesus' name. Amen. All right. Notice in first one, chapter two,
and you were dead in trespasses and sins in which you once walked following the
course of this world, following the prince of the power of the air,
the spirit that is now at work in the sons of disobedience.
Among whom we all once lived in the passions of our flesh,
carrying out the desires of the body and the mind, and were by nature children of wrath,
like the rest of mankind. But God, being rich in mercy because of the great love with which he
loved us, even when we were not in the flesh, we were not in the flesh.
Amen. Well, as we study this passage, let us look at the condition that people
have to live in. And we are going to be in the flesh. Amen.
And we are going to be in the flesh. Amen. Amen.
And we are going to be in the flesh. Amen.
And as this passage, let us look at the condition that people are in without Christ.
If you don't know Jesus Christ is your Savior, verses one and two describe your spiritual condition.
Now let's look at this. Notice the first word and that connects us back with chapter one.
And in there, we're told of how great and gracious God is and what he has done in order to bring us
to a point of salvation to know Christ as our Savior. But notice what Danny begins immediately,
describing the non-believer. And he says here, you were dead in trespasses and sins.
You were dead. That means completely indifferent to the things of God.
The person that's not a believer in Christ, they're on their own. They make decisions.
They think they're the charge of their path and their life and they're going to do what they're
going to do. And that's true. They are, but they're spiritually dead. They can't respond to God.
They can't choose God. There's no way they can do that. I worked part-time at a funeral home and
I was with a gentleman who'd lost his wife and he was in our chapel and staying in there.
And I took him in the chapel and I said, sir, I'm going to leave you for a few moments
to be with your wife. And I walked away and I got about four or five steps away and I heard him say,
she moved. And I thought, I'm going to keep going because if she moved, I'm not going to turn
around. And I thought, you can't do that. So I went back and as I was walking back, I thought,
now what are you going to say? And I walked up there and I said, sir, you said she moved.
And yeah, her hand, I saw her hand move. And I said, sir,
I know you want to see her move, but she's not there. That's her body.
That's what you relate to. But because of her faith in Christ, and we had had discussions before,
so I know she was a believer, but because of her faith in Christ, the lady that you loved
and loved her, she's with the Lord now. And when the Lord gets ready to call you home,
you'll be there with her. So don't when you're standing here, don't think of this body as this
is where she is. This is the body she lived in. This is the body that you loved and you cherished
and you took care of her, but she's not here. And he just kind of took a deep breath and
okay. And I quietly walked away. If you're here today without Christ, you're dead.
You are spiritually dead. You can't respond to Christ. You can't do anything to please him.
There's no peace. There's no joy. That's sad. That's sad. Now, not only are you dead,
but it goes on to say in trespasses and sin, trespassed is going beyond a moral boundary that's
been set. God has set a moral boundary on mankind and we're going to be held accountable by God for
the way we live. And because there are those who do not know Jesus Christ as Savior, they're going to
be going trespassing against God, the true and living God all their lives. And they don't even
realize it because they're spiritually dead, but God will hold them accountable. And then the trespasses
and sins, sin is defined as any lack of conformity unto or transgression of God's word.
And that's what sin really is. It's a spiritual condition. As you and I who have Jesus Christ as
our Savior, we still have to battle sin, but because we have spiritual life and we know what
sin does to us, it breaks the fellowship that we have between ourselves and the Lord. So we
strive by all God's pointed grace to be as free from sin as we possibly can.
And by the grace of God, we've been forgiven. We're free from that. But we're dead. The
lost person is dead in trespasses and sin. Now let's go on in to verse two here. Notice here,
he says, in which you once walked according to the course of this world, following the prince of the
power of the air in the spirit that is now at work in the sons of disobedience. Well, that's a mouthful.
First of all, look at the phrase in which you once walked. To walk there means to behave in a
certain manner. In Scripture, when you see the verb to walk, you have to look at your context
if it's walking from one city to another, you're walking. But if there's no physical movement,
that's your behavior. That's a behavior that you and I have. And the non-believer has that behavior.
But they are walking in sin and ungodliness. Notice he says, following the course of this
world, the world there means the distinctive features of the world. My dear brothers and sisters in
Christ, I have seen in this country in the last three years, the culture dictate to the church
what we're supposed to believe. And the sad thing is, there are some churches doing that.
Homosexuality is fine. Transgenderism is fine. No, it's not. It's going against the very core of
God and who He is and how He's created us, male and female, and how we're to have a relationship.
And churches are splitting over that. Churches shouldn't have to split over that if you know
the Bible. And so you and I must know the Scripture and we must stand on it, period.
And it's sad that we're seeing this take place in our lifetime. And there's all kinds of other sins
that Christians do not take seriously. Y'all ever been walking around and you get a little
bitty pebble in your shoe? And what do you do? Oh, it'll be all right. You just go right on. It'll
be all right. You won't be walking much longer. You stop, you take your shoe off, you get the
little pebble out, and you put that shoe back on. That's what it's supposed to be like.
That's the way sin is to our souls, our heart, our mind.
The peace is not what it should be. And when there's something upsetting your peace of
heart and mind, when there's something that's not just exactly right, I would say it's probably
some kind of sin that Satan's messing with you. You are aware of it because in Christ you are
spiritually alive and you need to do something about the sin which so easily ensnares us,
which means confess it, repent and ask for forgiveness. But the non-believer can't do that
because they're spiritually dead. And so they're in their sin, they're caught in sin. They follow
the course of this world. Please don't follow the course of this world. It's totally against God.
Notice it says also following the prince of the power of the air. The prince there is the power of
a supernatural being other than God, which is Satan. And the spirit of the air, look at that.
Now the spirit of the air that has to do is understood of the realm of evil.
Evil spirits, they're all over the place.
I had the privilege of serving in the air force for four years and my last year,
the Lord, because I volunteered to do this in a prayer, I said Lord I'll do anything you want
me to do. I'll go anywhere you want me to go if it means going to Thailand. I don't know why I
said Thailand, it just felt like a nice place. And so I got, I was, had real peace after I prayed that
prayer. One month before Mary Elner and I got married, I got a call. I was working in an office
on base and the clerk, squadron clerk said, trucks, I had to tell you about this. I said,
where in Thailand am I going? And he said, how did you know that I had these orders? And he gave me
the chain of command. And I said, let's just say I know someone in a real high place. He thought I
knew someone in the Pentagon. I wish I'd have thought about that four years earlier. I'd have
really been all right. But I was sent to Thailand. And while I was in Thailand, I had three
experiences with evil spirits. Let me tell you something, evil spirits are real.
It's real. And they're dangerous. And you and I need to be aware of the reality
of the presence of evil in the world in which we're living.
Satan wants us not to be serious about it. Oh, it's just a bad feeling. I'm just having a bad day.
Yeah. Do you know why you're having a bad day? Because the presence of evil. And you need to discern
it and be able to fight it in and through Jesus Christ. Notice here it says in verse two that
the spirit that is now at work in the sons of disobedience, disobedience there translates
refusal to follow authority. The authority that a believer follows is the father, the son, and the
Holy Spirit. And when we go against that authority, when you and I go against the word of God, we're
we're fighting the Lord and we're opening ourselves up even to more evil spirits. It's a dangerous
situation. But my dear brothers and sisters, this is what the nonbeliever is. When you're talking to
a nonbeliever, you're sharing the gospel with them and they don't understand. Don't get mad at them.
Don't get mad at them. They're dead. They can't understand. And what they need to be shown is
love and compassion and understanding, not condemnation, not judgmental attitude.
Show you really care. You're genuine. You want to, I want you to come to know Christ as Savior.
That's how you and I show love to a nonbeliever by be willing to listen to whatever ungodly thing
they're going to say or think, but not buy into it, but be ready to share the gospel of Jesus
Christ that they too may have eternal life. And so notice also as we're going into
to verse three, among whom we all once lived in the passions of our flesh, carrying out the
desires of the body and the mind, and were by nature children of wrath like the rest of mankind.
Oh my goodness. Look at that in which you once walked. Oh,
this is, uh, this is where we were before Christ. We lived in the passions of our flesh.
The word passion there,
it means carrying out the desires of the heart and the mind. And you and I who were in Christ,
we have passions. We have godly passions and godly desires and godly interests.
And always remember we're sinners saved by grace. We still have a pound of flesh in us.
Does it ever come out in you? Yeah. I'd like to follow you in your car
with us with a microphone in it and let somebody pull out in front of you.
Or some idiot, I'm excuse, see what I mean.
You know, see how easily we get tripped up. Yeah. We judge people.
I'm going to stop meddling. Okay. You get the idea. We got to fight that, that sin,
but one who is lost is dead interest passes and sin. They think it's okay.
It's, it's part of their lifestyle. And so they're going right on. They are going right on.
This is the passions that, that a non-believer has. Uh, and it's, it's very dangerous.
Not only is it the passion of the flesh, but carries out the desires of the body and the mind.
The body and the mind, we have desires, physical desires that we give into.
Okay. I'm going to confess my sin. I love sweet tea.
Oh my goodness. Mary Elner has a thing she makes with my, I'm not, this is not a commercial.
It's my love's tea and, and you have a gallon of it and you pour, uh, eliminate in it.
And, uh, then you pour water. Oh my goodness. I'm getting thirsty already.
But we have passions that originate in the body, physical passions,
immoral passions, greed, judgmental attitude. Any of you have a problem with anger? I don't.
Yeah. It's called sin. And you and I don't need to ignore it. We need to admit it to ourselves.
Just admit it. It's pretty simple. Yeah, Lord, I've got a judgmental attitude.
Yeah. I don't like that. I don't care for whatever it is.
Confession is admitting I've got sin.
Repentance means I'm sorry for it. And it also means because I'm sorry,
I'm going to turn away from it. I'm going 180. You know what happens if you go more than 180 on a
turn, you're going back where you came from. It means you stop it, cut it off.
And you and I as Christians, we have the spirit of God in us, the power of God
to overcome that sin, whatever it is. You might not think you can overcome it. You can.
You have. You've overcome certain sins in your life. You can continue to overcome that sin. You
have the power of God in you. A non believer doesn't have that. They cannot respond that way.
And so we see here that among those in the passions of our flesh carrying out the desires
of the body and the mind. Oh my goodness, the mind.
Why am I thinking that? Why do I have that kind of an attitude as a believer?
Shouldn't think that way. Shouldn't desire certain things. And so we have to admit that
and confess it and repent. But this is what a non believer is. Just lost as they can be.
And we're by nature, children of wrath. Children of wrath.
That's, that's a powerful word there. Wrath. It's the Greek word or gay.
There are two types of wrath. One is a slow burn. Another is a media harsh. And then it's, it's, it's gone.
This wrath is slow indignation. It burns. You have a fire, a nice fire going, you know, it's,
it's flaming up and it's burning. And then the fire burns down and maybe there are no flames.
You think that fire is out. What about the ashes underneath? They're still going.
It's still burning. That's what wrath is. It hangs on and it flares up when you least expect it.
Something happens. Somebody says something. Somebody walks by.
Some thought hits our minds and it puts us back into that mindset.
We have to guard our hearts with all diligence for out of it flow the issues of life.
This is a non believer, my dear brothers and sisters.
But this is something that creeps up in us from time to time. We have to repent and ask for
forgiveness because we have Christ as our Savior. Notice we're told where we have children,
we are children of wrath like the rest of mankind. Romans three, 23 for all of sin and fallen short
of the glory of God. There's not a single good person since Genesis chapter three from Genesis
three to the second coming of Christ. There's none good. No, not one. There's none who understands.
There's none who seek after God. We're inclined, the non believers inclined to go right opposite.
And there are times in our lives when you and I do the same thing. Then all of a sudden the Holy
Spirit says, what are you doing? What are you thinking? What are you desiring? And when you get
that call, then you need to confess and repent. But we don't need to be having a lifestyle that's
like a non believer because you and I and Christ are spiritually alive. And the believer spiritually
dead. Now that's that's pretty depressing. Let me move on here and notice by nature,
children of wrath like the rest of mankind. Everybody in this world apart from Christ is this way.
Now let's go to four and five. This is going to be much better.
Look at that phrase, but God. And when you're reading the Bible and you're reading the passage
and you come to the phrase, but God, pay attention to what comes after. That's good news.
That's really good. But God, what do we see about but God being rich in mercy? All right, let's stop
there. Being rich in mercy. First of all, let's look at the word rich. What does that mean?
Means an abundance. Means an abundance. What he has an abundance of mercy, mercy.
Mercy is demonstrating love. You know, we can say we love folks. I'm hearing that phrase a lot these
days. Love you. Love you. I want to stop and say how? Show me. God shows his love toward us.
And that while we were yet sinners, Christ died for us. Mercy is love in action.
Having mercy on someone is showing that love is reaching out to them, is having compassion for them,
is helping them out in their time of need. That's love in action. It's easy to say,
I love you. It's a lot more challenging to prove it. So we show mercy. This is what God
has done to us. You know, when Adam and the woman sinned in Genesis 3, you know what God could have done?
Could have killed both of them. And he would have been just in it. But he didn't. He showed mercy.
What did he do? He clothed them. How did he clothe them with animal skins? What had to
happen to the animal? Animal had to die. His blood had to be shed. It's the type of Christ.
Christ died for us. He was raised from the dead. We have eternal life as a result of that.
And so he's rich in mercy. Why is he rich in mercy? Because of the great love with which he loved us.
Even when we were dead in trespasses and sins, he made us alive together in Christ.
Notice he made us alive because we were spiritually dead and we didn't have the ability to be spiritually
alive. And so he shows us mercy by calling us to be his children.
And so you and I need to realize that and be willing to have mercy on the non-believer.
To have mercy on those who are struggling and they're just having a hard time.
So we were dead in trespasses and sin. He made us alive together with Christ.
By grace you have been saved. Saved means to be delivered or rescued from sin and judgment.
You and I have been rescued
and didn't even know it until such time we became believers and trusted in Christ.
So you see the difference here but God, rich in mercy because of the great love of which he loved
us, made us alive in Christ. This is so important. And so what is your spiritual condition?
What is your spiritual condition today? You know Jesus Christ is your savior.
I joined the church when I was nine.
Real owners of that was the pastor. And he baptized me, made a public profession of faith.
From age nine to age 20 there was no spiritual fruit. If you would have asked me if I was a Christian
now I said yes. Well I was like, wasn't that bad a kid?
And then I was in the Air Force and one Sunday night, one Wednesday night the pastor was teaching
D. James Kennedy's book Evangelism Explosion.
And this guy across the aisle from me said what if a guy loved his wife, his children,
is a deacon in the church, he works hard, pays his taxes, remember the church, been baptized,
but he doesn't have this personal relationship with Jesus Christ that you're talking about.
And the pastor said he's not a believer. He said I just described my life to you. This guy was a deacon.
And the pastor said everybody bow your head and pray you come up here. So I bowed my head and I went
uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
But I said there's no way I'm going to admit that in front of all these people.
So from Wednesday night to Sunday night I knew if I died I'd go to hell.
I was scared out of my wits. I was stationed in Louisiana at the time. Any of you from Louisiana?
I'm sorry. What part? Lafayette.
Those people in Louisiana we had a life storm and they don't know how to drive on ice. Scared me to
do it. They're great folks so. But I knew if I died I'd go straight to hell.
So that Sunday night, Sunday night, you know, it was a baddest church, great church.
And they were on the 35th verse of just as I am. And I've got a literally a white
knuckle grip on the back of that pew. I am not going down. The next thing I know I'm standing
there next to the pastor. He was kind of a little short guy and I'm shaking him saying what
do you mean by personal relationship with Christ? I don't know it.
He called one of his deacons over and they sat me down, went to the Roman road.
And I became a believer. Mielle and I were dating at the time. She's the first one I called.
Told her about it.
I said I'd never be a preacher. Can't do that.
I stopped saying can't after that. So here I am. But I was spiritually dead and didn't have a clue.
I thought I was good enough. No.
But what do you have to be saved from? And this really bothers me because we share the gospel of
Jesus Christ. But what do we have to be saved from? What's the point of salvation? Turn with me to
Revelation chapter 20. Revelation chapter 20 verses 11 through 15. This is the ultimate defeat of Satan.
And it's the judgment of the great white throne in Revelation chapter 20 verse 11.
Then I saw a great white throne and him who was seated on it. From his presence,
earth and sky fled away and no place was found for them. And I saw the dead great and small standing
before the throne and books were opened. Then another book was opened, which is the book of life.
And the dead were judged by what was written in the books according to what they had done.
And the sea gave up the dead who were in it. Death and Hades gave up the dead who were in them.
And they were judged each one of them according to what they had done. Then death and Hades were
thrown into the lake of fire. This is the second death, the lake of fire. And if anyone's name was
not found written in the book of life, he was thrown in the lake of fire.
An eternity in hell. Preachers don't preach like that anymore. What I have to be safe from
if it's cause I'm a bad guy, it's not all that bad.
But if it's an eternity of God's judgment in the lake of fire, I don't want that.
I'm not trying to scare anybody. I just want to be biblically honest with you.
Why do I need Jesus? Why do I need to be saved? Because if I'm not saved, if Jesus is not my savior,
then when I die, my name is not written in the Lamb's book of life. I will spend an eternity in hell.
But if my name is written in the book of life, Paul tells us in 2 Corinthians 5,
if this earth or house of our tabernacle were dissolved, we have a building of God not made
with hands eternal in the heavens. To be absent from the body is to be present with the Lord.
That's why all need Jesus Christ as savior. You don't get to heaven on your good works
because we have none until we have Jesus as our savior.
So I'm telling you my dear brothers and sisters in Christ,
if you have Jesus Christ as your savior, we are brothers and sisters and you have an eternity in
heaven. Think about that. That's awesome. We won't have to put up with any more sin that we're
having to deal with in this life. And you know how long we're going to be there? It's going to be
a long time eternity. But think about the lake of fire. Where are you going to spend eternity?
So I'd like for you to meditate on that.
Did you know for sure that when you die, you'll go to heaven because you have
complete trust and confidence and faith in Jesus Christ and Him alone for your salvation.
This is what Ephesians, how Ephesians starts out. It's all about eternity and where you're going to spend it.
So I hope and pray you do know Jesus Christ as savior. And if you don't,
Brandon can talk to you after the service. I'll be more than happy to talk to you after the service
and any believer in here will be happy to talk to you.
My harsh desire for you is that everyone of you know Jesus as savior
and will not have any doubt in your mind whatsoever.
Think about it. What is your understanding of your spiritual condition? Without Christ,
hopeless. With Christ, eternity in heaven with Him. With love and peace and joy that never ends.
I hope and pray you know Jesus Christ. Shall we pray?
Father in heaven, we love you because you first loved us and you sent your Son into the world to
die for our sins and to raise Him from the dead that through Him we have eternal life.
I pray for each one of my brothers and sisters here that you reassure them
of their faith in Christ, their hope in the Lord Jesus Christ. And I pray for those here today who
not real sure about whether they're going to be in heaven or hell. They're not real sure if
Jesus is their savior. Maybe they just think they're good enough to get into heaven. Whatever
it is Lord, work powerfully in their hearts, Holy Spirit. Bring them to a point where
they see they need Jesus as savior and pray to receive Him as savior. And I ask all of this in Jesus' name. Amen.